- Well, I mean, even my
mother, as a child, Mark.
My mother told me if you want
to be a hoe, be a good hoe.
If you're going to be
anything, be the best at it.
And that's what I tried to do.
- [Mark] All right, Jazzy.
- [Jazzy] Hey!
- [Mark] Jazzy.
Oh, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I am originally from Flint, Michigan.
I left Flint, Michigan
and moved to New York city
at around,
18 or 19 and stayed there for 17 years.
And then I left Flint.
I mean, I left New York,
and I met up with Pimping' Ken
and we went all across the South,
and I learned the game
and I that's how I got my introduction.
That's how I came into the game.
- [Mark] Let's go back to your family.
You had both parents growing up?
- I did.
My mother was very Masonic.
She was a Eastern star.
My grandmother and
grandfather were very Masonic.
My grandfather was very Masonic.
So they were all into
like, that whole world.
- [Mark] What does Masonic mean?
- Well, they're very,
very spiritual.
Some may call it, satanic.
I'm not on that side.
Even though my family was
very Eastern star-ish,
and Masonic and temple-ish,
I was, I do remember
taking oaths and pledges,
when I was younger,
because that's what my family was.
And that's what they were about.
Excuse my hands, it's a little ashy,
but that's what they were about.
And yeah.
I'm on a different side,
of the fence right now.
- [Mark] How was your childhood?
- I had a wonderful childhood.
My mother worked 32
years, at General Motors.
I didn't want for anything.
My father owned his own
construction company.
So, I was a very,
spoiled little girl.
I had everything I wanted growing up.
I mean, I didn't have perfect childhood.
My mother died when
she was, when I was 15.
So I was on my own after that.
You know, I had to take care of myself.
Flint, Michigan is very,
it's about the have and the have-nots.
You know, I've been hearing a lot lately,
where people are,
they put black people,
like light skin against dark skin
and that type of shit.
Growing up, it was about
the have and the have-nots.
So, you had it or you didn't.
I don't give a damn if you was light,
bright, white, disappearing.
You could have been a Geico
blended in with the grass.
I don't give a fuck.
If you didn't have no money,
or you didn't have things, you know,
people didn't want to fuck with you.
So I kinda made a name
for myself growing up.
I was very popular,
amongst my peers and, you know
I grew up having things.
And even after my mother died
I got into the game a little bit,
because I had to maintain,
I had an apartment at 15.
So, I had to maintain that lifestyle.
It was about like I said,
the have and the have nots.
It wasn't about light-skinned dark.
That's a stupid nigga argument, Mark.
I just want to let you know.
If you ever hear black folks arguing
about who's lighter, who's darker.
That's the stupid, poor nigga argument.
Okay, cause people, when
you have, you don't.
You know, not saying I
have a lot, you know,
but I grew up not wanting for anything.
So yeah, I had a good childhood.
- [Mark] But after your mom,
after you lost your mom.
- After I lost my mother, things got hard.
- [Mark] They got rough.
- It got rough.
Cause that was my mother.
You know, no matter
what we went through or,
what things I dealt with.
I mean, there was some abuse growing up,
and because I was adopted.
I was adopted at birth, but yeah,
I didn't want for shit.
And, I learned a lot
from seeing the black women
that I saw, they all worked.
They had husbands who was, you know
who equal or were equally yoked.
Everybody had money.
Everybody lived the lifestyle.
So I didn't see.
I mean, the things I see in here now.
Yeah. I wasn't, I didn't
see that growing up.
I mean, now I see a lot of shit.
Hell, I can't even live up
to the bitches that I saw.
- [Mark] So, the game.
- How my titties look?
- [Mark] You look amazing, Carla.
Absolutely.
From head to toe.
So you got into the game at, at what age?
Roughly?
- I would say about 15 on my own,
but a real introduction,
where I really learnt the game.
Okay. Well, when I moved to New York,
I worked in a whore house,
that was owned by the Italians.
It was owned by the mafia,
and it was only like
two black girls working,
out of bevy of white hoes.
So I worked there for a little while,
and then I met up with Pimping Ken,
cause he knew my first baby's daddy.
As we say in the hood,
he knew my first baby's father,
who was a well-known
rapper on a major label.
Not no underground,
he's well-known and I got introduced
to Pimping Ken, and I'm not
saying he was a pimp or not.
That's all allegedly, Mark.
I'm not saying he was a pimp,
because when I met him,
I mean, all this man did was read.
He wanted me to read.
He was very, very intelligent.
So this is a shout out to Ken.
I'm not trying to disrespect your name.
Love, you are a King,
and Dee, salute to you.
He taught me a lot.
We went all across the South,
and he just wanted me to
learn the ins and the outs.
- [Mark] So, your
experience with gentlemen,
that do that kind of work,
has been very positive?
- Yeah, very positive.
He never laid a hand on me.
And then, you know, of course I, you know,
I don't know if I said
this in the beginning,
but after I met him, I went to Milwaukee,
and I met the love of
my life, Pimp Snookie,
who I have a daughter with. Superior.
Hi, Pimp Snookie.
I love you.
- [Mark] He's in prison right now?
- He's in prison right now.
Free the King.
And no, I don't.
I mean, I have experiences as we all do,
but mostly positive.
I mean, these men showed
me how to get money.
I mean, nowadays, like
I see your show, Mark.
I see your show.
I see the caliber of people, you know.
And, a lot of them,
don't look like they got a pot to piss in,
or a window to throw it out.
And it's like, every guy that I dealt with
they all had money, and they
all knew how to get money.
It's like, how can you teach
somebody how to get money,
if you've never had money?
- [Mark] Well, I think
I've had the full range.
- Yeah, you have had a few.
You've had the Bishop on here, salute.
You've had, I mean, a lot of guys.
Hef, cause we both from Flint, Michigan.
Salute to you.
- [Mark] Kenny Red and Sharp, and Seymour.
- Kenny Red, Sharp, everybody.
You gotta get world famous play.
You gotta get Juju on here,
cause he is spectacular,
Juju, I love you, salute to you.
But yeah, this.
Back to me.
- [Mark] I'm just waiting for
Snookie, to get out of prison.
- We waiting on Snookie
to get out of prison,
because he is a, he is a spectacular man.
Yes he is.
And he taught me a lot.
And I wanna apologize
to Snookie on camera,
on your show
if that's okay,
because I may have said
things in the past,
online or because you know,
things get around online,
and I want to apologize to that King.
I am really sorry,
for anything negative that
I may have put out there,
against your name
because I didn't mean it.
You are spectacular.
We have a beautiful daughter together,
and you were a blessing
and you taught me a lot.
- [Mark] He is spectacular.
- I'm grateful for that.
I am grateful for that.
It was more good than it was bad.
- [Mark] So for you the game was,
it sounds like it was different,
than what it is for a lot of
the people I've interviewed.
Which is about drugs and about, you know.
- Yeah, I wasn't allowed to do drugs.
I wasn't allowed.
When I had a pimp,
which was only one that I'm going to say.
I mean, I'm not going to say that he was,
that's all alleged.
When I had Snookie, when I was with him,
I wasn't allowed to do drugs.
I was rarely allowed
to even drink alcohol,
let alone do a drug.
So I mean, because back then,
it's like, you know,
a drug dealer becomes
a whole 'nother pimp.
I mean, that's cutting into the money
that we're trying to make.
We're trying to build.
I mean, it's man owned
stores and nightclubs.
And I mean, he showed us the world.
We went all across country.
So it was, it was about more than just,
I would say pimping and hoeing.
I mean, it was a lifestyle.
When we talk about pimping
and hoeing in a game,
it's a whole lifestyle.
It's not just some man
beating up on a bitch,
and she's going to give
money and bringing it back.
No, it's a lifestyle.
We a family.
And we together,
I mean, so
- [Mark] You're playing a
game at a very high level.
- I was, well, I mean, even
my mother as a child, Mark.
My mother told me if you want
to be a hoe, be a good hoe.
If you're going to be
anything, be the best at it.
And that's what I tried to do.
You know, I tried to live up to that.
I wasn't, I wasn't
playing for small steps.
That's why I went.
I went to these men.
I went to Ken, I went
to Snookie, and I asked,
I asked for their help, so
that I could learn the game,
so that I could be the
best me that I could be,
and make the most money.
I mean, why I left?
I, first of all, let me explain to you.
I worked, I had a career.
I was a hairstylist in
Brooklyn for like seven years.
I was in hair magazines,
all doing all, you know
all over the place.
I had a career, I left my career,
and said, I gotta get this
hoeing' out of my system.
So I went, I found these men, you know.
I learned what I could learn.
And, I did it the best to my ability.
- [Mark] So, what do you
think about your system,
as you call it, attracted you to this?
Because you had a job.
- Once, you've turned your first trick.
Like I said, when my mother died,
I had to maintain, so I
kind of dibbled and dabbled.
Once you turn your first trick,
you never kind of go back.
You never kind of turn back
into a complete square.
So, even though I went to school,
I went to cosmetology school.
I finished high school.
I even went to college in New York.
I went to school for film and television.
It was never out of my system.
- [Mark] So what do you make
of that controversial comment,
Once a hoe, always a hoe?
You can't turn a hoe into a housewife?
- Well, I'm not going to
say you can't turn a hoe,
into a housewife.
You just have a housewife, that's a hoe.
You know, she got a little hoe in her,
but you can turn a hoe.
She can be a housewife now, you know,
but she going to be a housewife.
She going to be a hoe, that's a housewife.
That's all, but a good housewife.
Everybody, the pimp that I had, Snookie.
You had to know how to cook.
You had to clean, you
had to clean your body,
and wash your pussy 10 times a day.
So everything going to be smelling fresh,
the food going to be good.
That house going to be clean.
You're going to get fucked good.
And we gonna make our own money.
You know, these are the types
of hoes I grew up seeing, too.
My mother worked 32
years, aunties, everybody.
And they all had husbands who had equally,
if not more money than they had.
So yeah, I mean, so yeah.
You can turn a hoe into
a housewife, but no,
you probably not going to
have the type of housewife,
that's going to just sit there,
and just be at home, waiting on you.
No, we gotta get this money.
Let's turn this into an empire.
Let's build a pyramid.
Let's turn this into a legacy.
When we die,
we got statues and people
naming streets after us,
because this is what we have planted.
And this is the seed
that we have left behind.
- [Mark] So, back to my
other question, which was
what attracted you to the game?
When you already had a career?
- Well, I wanted to learn, I mean,
I was already selling pussy,
but I was doing it wrong.
So I wanted to learn how to do it right.
I mean, I worked everywhere
from Hunt's Point, Mark,
to Chicago, in the winter time at night.
I wanted to learn how to do it right.
I didn't want to end up dead,
and become just another dead black bitch.
I didn't want to,
have a criminal record, which I don't.
Okay. I see people up here, Mark.
And they have like,
we've been to jail.
You might find my mugshot,
for those of you that google
queen jazzy over here,
and follow me on
Instagram, queen jazzillah.
You might find my mugshot, but
all 'em charges was dropped.
And that was for assault.
And I don't have a criminal record,
and never in a gang, ever,
have I ever had a criminal record.
Cause that's not fly shit.
Like we was, I was taught by
the men that I worked with.
Cause, I don't want to say
pimps because that's illegal.
So, the men that I worked
with, that's not fly shit.
So we did everything we
could to not get arrested.
- [Mark] And the men you worked with,
were the best of the best.
- They were the best of the best.
And they taught you how
not to get arrested.
They taught you how cops speak,
and they do speak a certain way.
So you already know it's a cop,
when they calling you on the phone or,
you know, when you when you see him,
wherever you may be nowadays.
Cause I don't really know,
what these little hoes do nowadays.
But, back then. I mean, we
didn't, we weren't limited.
We worked wherever we could.
- [Mark] What kind of little tricks,
does a girl need to know to do this?
Like when you get in a guy's car,
you gotta make sure that door's
going to open from the inside, right?
- You gotta make sure it's
going to open from the inside.
Well you know, not too many people,
work the the blade now,
that was back then many years ago.
But with a call service, even with.
Even if you were an
escort, cause I have been.
- [Mark] There's, plenty of
girls working the blade still.
- Really?
I, I have been a, I was an escort.
I worked in hoe houses.
I worked on the blade.
I worked in strip clubs.
So I had done it all.
There was nothing, there was nowhere,
that I had no ground that I didn't cover.
You just have to listen out,
for certain things that they say.
If a trick call you,
and automatically he offering
you say thousands of dollars,
without even knowing you
or getting to talk to you
or knowing you, nine times
out of 10, that's a cop.
When you get, like, if you
get in a car with a guy, yes
you got to make sure the
car opens from the inside.
You look in the back,
make sure he ain't got nobody
jumping out the back seat.
Tell him to go to a spot that you know,
don't let him control it.
Just certain things.
You can't let a trick ever
control the situation, period.
- [Mark] So, did you have any
bad experiences doing that?
- Of course, I did.
When I first got in the game,
I did get raped in Chicago
by a white guy, got in the
car, didn't check the door.
Like I just told y'all to do,
didn't check the door, okay.
And it was locked from the inside.
And then he put a knife,
to my head and said, I'm a rapist.
I'm not a murderer.
But if you make me, I will kill you.
And at the time I think I might've been,
like two months pregnant.
Okay. I don't mean to put
that out there, but I am.
I'm just going to keep
it all the way funky.
I was like two months
pregnant and I was working.
Yes I was.
And he took me to a warehouse,
and I had to use the game
the little bit of game that
I had had at that time,
because I had just got in the game,
to finagle my way out of that situation,
with my life or my daughter's life.
I was unhaved, scarred, anything.
I did get raped though.
I did have to go to the hospital.
Didn't have no diseases, none of that.
But, I was, I was alive.
So that was a bad experience
and I never forgot it.
And I paid attention after that.
Cause that, that came from
me, not really listening
and paying attention to what I was told.
- [Mark] So, when you're
working with a man,
like Pimping Ken, or Snookie,
you're bringing him how much of the money?
- Oh, All of it.
- [Mark] And he does what with that?
- Well, I want all that game.
So, you know, you got to
give them all the money.
I don't want half of the knowledge.
I mean, the things that they taught me
I still live by today.
So they made sure they made
sure I was taken care of.
I mean Snookie.
I mean I had my own house.
I traveled cross country.
I mean, I had everything I needed.
There were, there were plenty of cars.
I mean, nobody wanted for anything
and I wasn't the only girl.
So yeah, nobody wanted
for, we played to win.
We didn't play to, like,
it wasn't, you know,
nowadays I hear stories about girls.
It's like 50 of them in one hotel,
and they selling pussy
to pay for the room.
When that shit is insane.
The pimp living in a room with them,
they all selling pussy,
just so they could pay
for one room at the Motel
Six, which is $40 at best.
So yeah, that shit is insane.
No, we had to pay for our own rooms.
We went from state to state.
We had to make our own way.
There was a,
minimal of $500 a day,
that Ms. Jazzy had to check in,
and this was back then,
and $500 a day I did,
more than that but,
I had to add minimal,
check that in every single
day when I was cross-country.
So that, that was just,
you know, back then.
I don't know.
I see them now.
I mean, it's a little sloppy.
Some black eye on the game right now.
I see it now.
And I'm not here to
downplay anything as far as,
sex trafficking or anything like that.
It's all bad.
If you pimping and under age girls,
that shit is all bad and disgusting,
but I'm here on another side of the game.
You know, I have a, I don't have a,
I don't have a really a bad story.
I learned a lot.
I mean, I'm doing very well right now.
I just finished school for accounting,
well I got a certificate after
I finished the course, okay.
Let me not big myself up like that.
But I mean, I am doing
great things right now.
I overcame a lot.
I work two full-time jobs.
I paid for, I pay my
house note every month,
my car note.
My daughter got a new car
that she just totaled.
- [Mark] You have how many kids?
I have two grown daughters.
- [Mark] You raised them?
- I raised them,
18 and 29.
So two grown daughters,
one lives in California.
The other one is in Milwaukee,
the one by Snookie.
- [Mark] Were drugs ever
a part of your life?
- [Jazzy] Yes. Drugs
was a part of my life,
after I left the pimp,
and not during,
I did get into drugs.
I started snorting Coke for long time
- [Mark] While you were, while
you were working the street?
- [Jazzy] No.
When I went back to New York.
This was after I kind of left again,
but then I got back into it.
I was escorting, but not,
I didn't have a pimp.
- [Mark] So you were escorting,
on your own?
- [Jazzy] On my own, this was years later.
Yeah, I was going through mental issues.
Yeah. I went through a lot.
I had to go in and out of
hospitals for mental issues
and just, I mean the
game, I guess, the game
and just growing up, just
my life being targeted,
and doing things that I'd done.
It took a toll on me and it caught up,
but I just, you know I don't
even want to paint that picture
because I was never a victim, but yeah
I did turn to drugs, Mark.
I got so bad at one time
I started shooting up,
slept in a park, but I woke
up from that park, you know
and I don't, I've been
clean two years today.
I don't so much as drink alcohol.
I don't do any drugs, not weed, nothing.
Don't take pills.
Don't take Tylenol.
I fast, I pray.
I work two full-time jobs,
pay my bills and look beautiful.
- [Mark] You sure do.
- [Jazzy] That's what I do.
Did you ever get depressed
doing this kind of work?
- I wouldn't say
depressed, but be lovesick.
Cause I was really like,
I love Snookie with all my heart.
So back then, you know,
he was my first love and yeah.
I didn't know how to deal with
my emotions, but I loved him.
So yeah, I would get love sick,
not depressed, but love sick.
Like who he fucking tonight,
you know, that's goofy shit.
But no, I certainly
don't get depressed now.
- [Mark] And is it possible,
to have a real love relationship,
while you're doing that
kind of work, for a girl?
- Well, back then that wasn't real love.
I mean, you and the gentleman,
that you were breaking bread with,
that was a real love relationship
because that was our reality.
So it wasn't, I mean, I
wasn't square at the time.
So that was.
- [Mark] But, even though
you were having intimate interactions
with multiple guys every night.
- Well, I feel, let me clear something.
I wasn't, I was taught different.
So, I wasn't a flatback hoe,
I really didn't fuck a lot of men.
I would be lying if I
said I never had sex,
with any of the guys that I saw,
I didn't do a whole lot of fucking,
I mean, it was very rare.
I mean, my customers,
most of them were white.
Okay. Like I hear you ask the questions.
You should ask some of these hoes.
Like, what did you prefer?
You know, I might've been a racist hoe.
I mean, I liked white men
cause they spent more money,
and they asked for less activity.
You know, you see a black man for $50.
He want to fuck you all night,
have your upside down,
twerking on your head,
one cheek, left cheek.
I don't have time for that.
I don't want to sweat.
I don't want to mess my weave up.
You know, my eyebrows is perfect.
I don't want to do none of that.
So, you know, I saw mostly white men,
and they took care of me long
after I got out of the game.
- [Mark] So they they're treating you more
like a girlfriend?
- Yeah, like a queen, like a girlfriend.
- [Mark] So this kind of work,
it builds up your self esteem,
or ultimately takes it
down, breaks it down?
- I would say a combination of both,
but in my case my self-esteem
was already built.
I mean, my mother and
father did a wonderful job.
So I'm not going to blame any
downfall I had, on the game.
I mean, I went through
a lot in life, period.
That kind of caught up,
like my mother's death.
She died in front of me.
My father died, my grandmother.
So my brother, a lot of
things caught up with me.
So I'm not gonna say it was the game.
The game has been,
believe it or not,
has been sort of a plus for me,
because I learned a lot, and
it provided me with a family.
That'll always be my family,
you know, no matter what.
Shout out to Shameeka, Monet Avery,
just saluting you, queen.
Yeah, a family that I
always consider my family.
So I don't really have
nothing bad to say about it.
- [Mark] So looking back at your life,
do you have any regrets?
- Maybe exposing my kids to what I doing.
Well, at that time I
only had one daughter,
and taking my youngest from
her father, which was Snookie,
when she was three months old.
I regret that because
of whatever me and him,
was going through at the time.
So I do regret that, I
do regret certain things,
that I had to expose them to.
And later on in life, believe it or not
you will have to explain to
your kids what was going on.
And yeah, the situations at hand.
So, I do regret exposing my
children to certain things,
because I take being a
mother very seriously.
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- The beginning, when I first met Snookie,
and being a mother, just
giving birth to both of my kids
but when I first met Snookie,
it was just me and him,
me and him against the world.
There was nothing, there
was no outside coming in.
There was no nothing.
It was just me and him.
- [Mark] What about the girls?
- Well, there was girls but, you know.
At that time, he made me feel
like it was all about me.
So at that time that was,
I would say that moment
right there was, was
one of the best moments,
of my life and then
giving birth to my kids.
Not in no particular order,
for those of y'all that's going to say,
not her kids?
No, that it wasn't in a particular order,
but love is the best time in my life.
So both of those situations,
symbolized just me being in love.
- [Mark] What was the worst time?
- My mother's death.
And I just lost an uncle.
That took a lot on me,
and my father's death.
Yeah. Having to deal with any death,
having to deal with
somebody I love, dying.
- [Mark] So because your game,
your memories of the game
or your experience with it,
is so different than everyone else's.
The question I ask a lot of the girls is,
What is the most misunderstood
thing about this lifestyle?
And it'd be interesting,
to hear your answer to that question
- Well, people think
that the game consists,
of some man beating on you all the time,
and you giving him all your money,
and he's forcing you to do things.
When I found, I chose
Snookie, like I came to him.
I literally handed him
few thousand dollars
and I mean, not, okay.
I don't want to, cause I
don't want to implicate,
that he was doing anything illegal.
This is all allegedly.
So, but, and I was in my twenties.
I was in my late twenties.
I wasn't a young girl.
I left New York, came to him
and it was all by choice.
- [Mark] So you chose him?
- I chose him.
- [Mark] And you had to
pay to be part of his
- Well, in the beginning, yeah.
I had to pay to be a part,
because they want to know you serious.
You know? So.
- [Mark] I got to use that.
- Yeah. He had already done,
like pimps up hoes down
and things like that.
So he already had a name.
So they want to know that you serious,
and you are who you say you are.
So yeah, I had to, but I
was well in my twenties
I was like 27 years old, then.
Even though I look 27 now.
- [Mark] You do look, 24.
- Okay.
But no, I'm not, she's not.
Her daughter's 29, but
yeah, I was 27 then.
So yeah, no.
The people have misconceptions
that you being forced
and made to do things when you're not.
When I was tired and ready to go,
Ms. Jazzy packed her bags,
and left and never
returned, never returned.
- [Mark] How is Jazzy different after,
those seven years, five
years, than she was before?
- Cause Jazzy is over the top.
Jazzy is over the top.
I'm very honest, very
straight up, very uncut.
- [Mark] Did it make you
a little more streetwise?
- It made me a little, it
made me a lot more streetwise.
Very open and honest.
I saw and I paid attention.
I paid attention to
everything that I learned.
Some of the most memorable times was like,
I'm just going to say this me and Snookie
would have these talks in the park.
I'm not going to say what they were about,
but it was just so intense.
And so, just learning and
just paying attention.
So it has made me very streetwise,
10 steps ahead of people,
like 10 steps ahead of the game.
I've been able to overcome a lot.
- [Mark] So, being with
a pimp like Snookie,
a man like that really coaches,
it's a life coach, almost.
- He was a life coach.
He was, he was my everything.
He was my everything.
And he still is to a degree.
So, you know, I still listen to him,
even to do this interview.
I asked him if it would be okay.
- [Mark] Did you find you got
addicted to that lifestyle?
- I did.
It is very addictive, Mark.
It is almost like a drug.
And, I found myself,
I had to go to groups.
- [Mark] What is it?
I mean, cause you weren't doing drugs.
What is it, that's addictive about it?
- The whole lifestyle, the
camaraderie, the money, the guy.
I mean the, just being with
the gentleman that I was with,
I was addicted to him.
I was addicted to the
rollercoaster relationship,
that it was.
I mean, it's everything
about it is addictive.
Traveling, not having to answer to any,
I mean, well, you had to,
I had to answer to somebody, but you know,
not clocking in, being your
own boss is kind of rebellious.
It's very rebellious
and you feel very free,
and you know, kind of like a warrior.
- [Mark] And once you've
been exposed to it,
it's going to be really
hard to go back to it.
- It's very hard.
It's very hard.
And I, yeah, like I said, I
had to go to a lot of groups
like, Hi, my name is Jazzy.
Not, not necessarily
about, but just talk about,
just everything to kind
of distance myself,
from the lifestyle
and just kind of be the
big old square bitch
that I am right now, a little bit.
Not all the way.
- [Mark] What's the most important thing,
what have you learned about human nature,
from doing this kind of work?
- Just that being honest,
is freeing and the most important thing,
and family is everything.
So just, you gotta have
your priorities straight.
I mean, a lot of people thinks, you know.
Material things are good to have.
I mean, but that's a temporary fix.
You want your family to be in place.
You want your kids to be all right.
You want to learn from
people as much as you can,
so that you can prosper
and leave a legacy behind,
you know.
I don't want to die,
and then there's no
legacy for my children.
My mama was a hoe, that's the story.
You know, that's my eulogy at my funeral.
My mama was a hoe,
and then they dropped the mic
and walk off the stage, you know?
And I did a lot of things.
You know, my mommy was a writer.
She wrote a book, stay tuned for my book.
Okay. Any publishers out there?
Satan is a black man,
that will be about me and Snookie and,
Volunteer slaves, my second book.
So stay tuned for that.
But yeah, I didn't, I
wanted to leave a legacy,
and not just, you know, have my kids talk
about they mother and
they father in the gang.
So to speak.
Not that that's a bad
thing because you know,
we did all right.
But, that's the most important thing.
Just being honest and,
and living an honest life
and trying to do right by people.
I always try to, even in the
game I did right by people.
I never tried to step on toes,
and that could be why
I'm still alive today.
- [Mark] All right, Jazzy.
Well, thank you so much
for sharing your story,
and I wish you the best of luck.
- [Jazzy] Thank you.
- [Mark] Thank you.